come behind the scenes with us Ches
who's directing we had a ton of fun
watching Jessie on Disney Channel just
maybe not as much as the cast had making
it there were a ton of laughs and more
than a few pranks going on behind the
scenes will reveal who was the ultimate
prankster and which cast member was the
most uncooperative we loved seeing the
characters on Jessie have so much fun
together in each new episode but the
laughs didn't always stop when the
cameras did according to Peyton lists
the cast members were all incredibly
close and spent a lot of time getting to
know each other maybe even a little bit
too well in one case one of their
favorite games was to do impressions of
each other and Peyton claims that they
got way too good at it since they were
so used to each other's mannerisms and
ways of speaking one healthy breakfast
coming up debby ryan may have been one
of the older actors on set but that
doesn't mean she didn't do her share of
goofing around
according to her co-stars Cameron Boyce
and Karan Brar we shouldn't be fooled by
a Debbie's innocent face because
backstage this gal was the ultimate
prankster and loved to play jokes on
everyone but Cameron said he managed to
fool her once by attaching a fake spider
to a stick and placing it on her leg
although Debby may have started the
prank war Cameron and Carr and had no
problem keeping it going
he was pranking all of us I mean all of
us and then we're gonna get you back
characters on Jessie spent a lot of time
in Central Park and apparently this
particular set piece is popular behind
the scenes as well
Cameron boys pointed out that filming on
location would be impossible due to the
amount of people who visit the park so
they recreated it on set instead of a
green-screen
they used a giant photos taken of
Central Park as a backdrop but all the
playground equipment was very real
[Music]
and Debbie admits they enjoyed swinging
on the swings between scenes also the
hallway is the common scene in the show
but in reality those doors don't really
lead anywhere all of the rooms are
located in different areas being a part
of the Ross households can be a little
challenging in time
Debbie acts as the kids nanny but
apparently she was more interested in
helping them cause trouble behind the
scenes at least according to actor Kevin
Chamberlin he claims that Debbie had the
great idea of giving everyone devices
designed to launch marshmallows and
things quickly got out of hand according
to Kevin the kids loved bursting into
his dressing room to Pelt him with
marshmallows but at least he had a good
sense of humor about it another popular
food based activity onset was combining
soda and mentos to create sticky
explosions these pranks were all in good
fun but there was one member of the
Jesse cast who was notoriously difficult
to work with mr. or should we save mrs.
Kipling meet Frank a 65-pound Asian
monitor lizard according to his trainer
Joule Sylvester he's basically a
crocodile with lips and he's not the
most cooperative creature in the world
according to Karan Brar Frank tends to
do whatever he wants at all times
mrs. Kipling or Frank he was actually
really mellow which is usually the
opposite of what the scene calls for for
scenes a puppet is used instead for the
safety of the actors and to show the
lizard doing something they won't do on
the road but originally mrs. Kipling
wasn't going to be a lizard at all but
rather a capybara and and they actually
call him you mrs. Kipling the cast of
Jessie had a lot of fun spending time
with each other and they also got to
interact with some other Disney Channel
stars according to sky Jackson they
shirts space with the cast of lab rats
but the other show's cast had some
things they didn't namely a slushie
machine and a popcorn machine Skye says
they would frequently sneak over for
slushies and snacks that they couldn't
get on their own set Cameron Boyce was
such a popular actor that it's easy to
forget that there was a time when he was
just starting
in fact he said he was positively
starstruck when Debbie Ryan herself
called him to tell him that he'd gotten
apart on Jessie at first he wasn't sure
if it was really her and then he was
convinced that she was pulling a prank
on him he said that the first time they
met she picked him up and twirled him
around to welcome him to the set
interestingly enough his descendents
co-star dove Cameron admits the first
time she met Cameron she also felt
compelled to wrap her arms around him
apparently Cameron is just a really
huggable guy so this thing will make me
say what I really feel to June looking
at Josie tota now you might not
recognize her as the star that played
Stuart wooden her time on Jessie was
before her transition and it was
difficult feeling like she couldn't
really be herself on set
Josie claims that she knew she was a
girl from an early age but a took her a
while to realize what that meant
although she loved spending time with
her Jessie co-stars she admits that she
prefers being able to take on roles that
represent who she really is
looks like someone does have it in for
you I just got the most interesting
anonymous tip what are you talking about
the cast of Jessie looks so cute
together that it's hard to imagine any
of them fighting so it's no surprise
fans were stunned to hear Debbie and
Skye were embroiled in a bitter feud
there were rumors Skye had a secret
Twitter account to talk about Debbie who
refused to comment directly on
allegations of negativity between them
online trolls even tried to make it look
like Skye had answered angrily when
asked about her relationship with Debbie
but Skye clarified that she's got
nothing but love for her former co-star
[Music]
this show had a great cast as well as
some notable guest stars but according
to Karan Brar he wished they would have
had an episode with his celebrity crush
Hunger Games actress Jennifer Lawrence
we're getting married by the way she
doesn't know it but you know but even
though she's no Jennifer Lawrence he was
excited to meet former First Lady
Michelle Obama and admitted that he was
more nervous around her than her husband
Peyton list was also over-the-top
excited about getting to meet Michelle
Obama describing it as a dream come true
mrs. Obama also had a good time on the
show and paid tribute to Cameron after
his passing remembering
having an incredible talent and an
incredible heart you see both the
President and I know how much children
do for our country
having your first kiss on camera is
awkward but even the idea of smooching
on screen was enough to scare Peyton
lists apparently she saw Emma's first
kiss on a list of possible plot points
and it caused her to panic about the
idea of doing so in front of all of her
cast members sometimes feeling like
family with your co-workers is a good
thing but not when you have to do a
potentially embarrassing scene in front
of them Karan Brar fell in love with
acting right away but getting the right
accent for Jessie definitely took some
practice if we are capsizing and you
cannot find your lifejacket what is the
most suitable floatation device yes
Karan had to learn to speak with an
Indian accent to portray Ravi Ross
because he has an American accent in his
day-to-day life it took a lot of work
with a dialect coach but Karan said it
was all worth it because he loved being
a part of Jessie
still angry and even if you're a major
fan of the show there's some footage you
might not have seen this family-friendly
show actually had a major controversy at
some point surrounding the episode
quitting cold koala originally the
episode was going to have some jokes
poking fun at Stuart's the sensitivity
to gluten it's but many parents were
upset about it
Disney ended up having to apologize and
edit the episode to remove the offending
content apparently the company didn't
realize that the public doesn't support
intolerance of gluten intolerance sure
it has a few minor dietary requirements
a shortage list studios want to make
sure that a show is going to be
successful both bored they invest too
much time money and resources into
making it which is why they usually have
a pilot episode this is an initial
episode which is then reviewed and used
to determine how many episodes of the
show should be ordered or if it's not a
good fit for the channel but Disney was
so confident about the success of Jessie
that they ordered episodes upfront
without waiting to see if the pilot
episode could pass the test these these
guys are you know how we make it happen
cuz without them we couldn't do what we
love but this doesn't mean
were not some revisions from the
original Jessie line up earlier we told
you that mrs. Kipling was nearly a
capybara but she was also going to be
owned by a character named Javier a
bilingual boy from South America but
Javier ended up being changed to Ravi
when the casting director discovered
Karan Brar and just had to have him on
the show Christina Ross was going to be
a photographer named Pandora with a much
bigger role emma was going to be named
Annabel and Luke was going to be a boy
from Korea named high rope and then brag
to her friends about how far she's video
during a zoom reunion the Jessie Casta
shared some touching memories about
their lay co-star Cameron Boyce Debby
claims that Cameron was there to comfort
her while her mom was going through
chemotherapy treatments and that he
seemed to sense something was bothering
her on set Peyton and Kevin remember
Cameron as a fantastic dancer who was
always showing off his moves behind the
scenes and getting people to laugh while
Cameron had been starstruck about
meeting Debby Skye said that she was
excited to work with him after seeing
him on Dancing with the Stars let me
guess
ladies man in the beginning Emma's
outfits were born out of a collaboration
between the costume department and
Peyton's own closet many of Emma's
accessories and clothes in the first
season were actually Peyton's
but before long their styles were pretty
much in sync
according to Payton the cast had the
opportunity to purchase items from their
wardrobe at the end of each season and
she always took full advantage of
getting first dibs at Emma's clothes but
she admits the one major difference in
their looks
is that Payton loves to wear high heels
and so we get first dibs on everything
so I'm probably going to be trying to
get first dibs on all of them his
wardrobe Debbie wasn't just the star of
Jessie she was also the reason the show
existed creator Pamela Ilocano loved her
on the suite life on deck so much that
she based a new show around her not only
did it give Debbie a chance to keep
working with Disney but she also had the
opportunity to become the youngest
director on the channel and Pamela had
plenty of experience working on sitcoms
involving nannies since she had worked
on both the Charles in Charge and the
nanny during her career she knew Debbie
had the skills and had the smarts and
together they could create something
truly special when I'm directing
I feel like I'm firing on all cylinders
ready when Jessie ended many fans were
upset and wondered what had gone wrong
behind the scenes but according to
Debbie there's no great mystery here the
show just ended because it ran its
course a little anticlimactic but at
least the show had a good run Debbie
made Disney Channel history by becoming
the youngest director and by being the
first protagonist on a show to get
married it was also unique that her
character had graduated high school and
wasn't yet a college student in real
life
Debbie quietly got married - Joshua Dunn
of the band twenty one pilots she claims
it was a last-minute decision and the
newlywed couple couldn't be happier
about it what do you think of the fact
that debbie ryan played a new character
instead of continuing her role of Bailey
on the suite life on deck do you think
four seasons was enough or do you miss
him Jessie on TV let us know what you
think and share your favorite episode
with us and your fellow Disney fans in
the comment section thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more great videos